le manque d'accès aux vaccins dans les
pays pauvres et émergents a certainement
créé les conditions parfaites pour
l'apparition du variant au micro selon
oxfam les pays d'afrique subsaharienne
ont des doses pour vacciner -2 13% de la
population avec nous ce soir agathe deux
marais directrice des prévisions
mondiales pour 10 economist intelligence
unit à londres madame de marée bonsoir
pensa d'abord comment on explique
l'arrivée du va rien au micron qui est
quand même beaucoup plus contagieux que
les autres variole
alors l'arrivée du barrio micro en fait
n'est pas une surprise y avait toujours
été attendu qu'il aurait d'autres
variantes du courroux des virus après la
question c'est la transmissibilité la
sévérité et la résistance potentielle au
vaccin mais l'arrivée d'un micron n'est
pas une surprise et en fait c'est
probablement dû aux inégalités vaccinale
puisqu'on voit que le variant au micro a
émergé en afrique du sud au botswana qui
sont des zones qui ont eu en fait moins
accès aux vaccins que les pays riches
les pays développés et au micron a
probablement en fait émerger à cause de
ces inégalités nationale donc le manque
de vaccins est et le manque de personnes
vaccinées la faiblesse du taux de
vaccination
créer un lieu dans le fond où peuvent se
développer de nouveaux variants
oui absolument puisque en fait lorsqu'on
est contaminée par le coronavirus le
virus mute dans chacun d'entre nous et
on fait ce qu'on voit c'est que le
variant au nippon a énormément de
mutation et donc la théorie scientifique
qui accourent évidemment elle n'est pas
prouvée mais cela ait eu la théorie la
plus plausible actuellement serait que
au micro en fait se réduire la
contamination d'une personne
immunodéprimées par exemple une personne
qui aurait le sida qui vous recevrez des
chimiothérapies contre un cancer est la
personne en fait son système immunitaire
n'est pas arrivé à se débarrasser du
corps analystes rapidement donc le
coronavirus a beaucoup lutté et c'est
pour cela qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui
elle vient leproux qui a de très
nombreuses mutations qui le rendent
partiellement résistant au bac 5 vous
nous avez préparé une carte de la
couverture vaccinale
actuelle dans le monde où on voit qu'en
bleu par exemple ce qui est en bleu on
voit le canada les états-unis il ya des
pays d'europe également ou à la fin 2021
on prévoit une couverture généralisée de
la vaccination mais ce qui était en
rouge et c'est en grande partie les pays
d'afrique et une partie du moyen orient
là ça va jusqu'à 2023 avant que la
vaccination soit complétée
oui tout à fait leur en fait ce qui
frappe quand on regarde cette carte
c'est que c'était cette année ou
peut-être jamais c'est à dire que
l'ensemble des pays développés dont vous
citiez les états unis le canada les pays
de l'union européenne
une certaine partie de l'amérique latine
également vous avoir vacciné la majorité
de la population 60 à 70% de la
population cette année en revanche qu'on
voit c'est que la plupart des autres
pays dans le monde en fait la
vaccination à s'étirer jusqu'en 2023 et
on sait ce que cela veut dire c'est que
la vaccination n'aura peut-être pas lieu
dans un certain nombre de pays africains
ce qui va poser le risque que de
nouveaux variants après au micro
continuent à émerger en permanence et
nous ramène au point de départ mais
vraiment ce qui frappe c'est que c'était
cette année ou peut-être jamais pour la
vaccination dans la plupart des pays du
monde et donc il faut s'attendre à de
nouveaux variants 2022 alors oui
absolument absolument l'hypothèse selon
laquelle on travaille nos chevilles et
quand même mais souhaiterait tout de
suite c'est qu'il y aura au moins un à
de nouveaux variants en 2022 alors après
ce n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle puisque le virus mutent en
permanence et les mutations qui reste
communiquerons peuvent être celles qui
sont plus transmissible mais ça ne
signifie pas nécessairement même si à
nouveau rien n'est prouvé pour l'instant
que le virus sera plus sévère qui
donnera plus de formes graves et cela
pourrait être en fait le chemin du virus
vers l'endémicité puisque les
coronavirus que l'on connaît le mieux ce
sont des rhumes et peut-être que dans
plusieurs décennies le corps d'un virus
deviendra un rhume banal mais pour
l'instant c'est malheureusement la
maladie koné défend très sévère on
pourrait passer de la situation pendé
mais que nous connaissons à une
situation endémique la coved va
continuer d'exister mais ce ne sera plus
considérée comme une pandémie - une
pandémie
absolument c'est le chemin d'un an daily
cité et le virus pourrait bien devenir
endémique alors c'est quoi les grains un
jeu de vaccination actuelle main en un
an et où on s'en va ou en 2022
alors je dirais qu'en 2022 il y aura
trois grands thèmes le premier thème
c'est évidemment les dose de rappel dans
la plupart des pays développés lui ce
qu'il faut noter que dans les pays
riches on discute de dose de rappel mais
dans les pays pauvres on discute
toujours de première dose mais comme on
voit que l'on court résiste
partiellement quand on n'a reçu que deux
doses de vaccin c'est ce que montrent
les études scientifiques préliminaire
le fait d'avoir une dose de rappel une
troisième dose sera clé dans les pays
riches pour essayer de lutter contre la
déferlante on y trouve donc ça sera une
première thématique la deuxième
thématique les inégalités vaccinale
bourg est évidemment continuer les pays
en fait les plus pauvres notamment en
afrique vous continuez à avoir des
difficultés d'accès aux vaccins on peut
également imaginer que si les sociétés
pharmaceutiques font des mises à jour de
leurs vaccins contre au micro on peut
tout à fait imaginer qu'on aurait lui
coexistence des deux vaccins un contre
au micron plutôt dans les pays riches et
le vaccin actuel qui serait peut être
administré dans les pays pauvres donc
les inégalités vaccinale vont continuer
une ce à quoi on s'attend chez les gones
mais ce tour james unis c'est en fait
des débats dans un certain nombre de
pays pauvres concernant l'urgence de
vacciner contre le corner virus est ce
que cela doit être une priorité de santé
un certain nombre de pays pour les
décidé que finalement ils ne vont pas
vaccinés et enfin la dernière thématique
ce avec toujours la diplomatie vaccinale
notamment de la chine et comment celle
ci va s'adapter à l'émergence dominant
est ce que ça pourrait faire dérailler
la reprise économique oui tout à fait
alors en fait chez écolo mais cette
origine si nous avons mis des
probabilités vous aurez une probabilité
de près de 55% donc la majorité des cas
pour que le variant au micro fasse
dérailler la reprise économique puisque
si l'on doit à nouveau introduire des
mesures de confinement dans les pays
riches puisque nous avons une thématique
des les riches et pays pauvres souvent
n'ont pas le luxe de faire les
confinements et bien évidemment ça va
avoir un fort impact sur la croissance
sur le tourisme sur les échanges
commerciaux et on pourrait tout à fait
se retrouver dans la même situation que
celle dans laquelle on était des bus
2020 retour à la case départ donc est ce
que c'est votre scénario majoritaire sa
probable en 2022
alors à ce stade en fait on attend
d'avoir des données concernant la
sévérité de mouscron pour vraiment se
prononcer notre scénario de base serait
que si au micro n'est pas plus sévère
que le variant delta cela ne va
peut-être pas avoir un impact majeur sur
la reprise économique mais si au micro
est aussi sévère ou plus sévère que
dalle était à ce moment là ce serait une
catastrophe pour la reprise économique
puisqu'il y aura beaucoup plus de cas
est donc beaucoup plus d'admissions dans
les hôpitaux
c'est très intéressant agathe de marie
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit